- All right, the score
is two, nothing girls!
Bit of a button hog over
here, but here we go.
Who's our next famous voice?
- Now listen boys, I wanna let you know
that I was the sexiest man alive.
- Oh that's good.
- Oh, oh I know that one!
- John Legend.
- Morgan Freeman.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- [Carson] That is correct!
The boys are on the board!
- [Kelly] Damn it!
- How do you do that?
- I knew that one, damn it!
- Yes!
- Two to one!
- [Gwen] Two against one.
- Good voices, he's doing good.
- Morgan Freeman, that was
amazing, Morgan Freeman.
- He's really good!
- Gosh, I am not good at this.
- I appreciate that, I will
narrate to you for free.
- [Carson] Wow.
- That's all right, I got you boo.
- That's fine.
- Morgan what did you do after
you got out of Shawshank?
- After I got out of Shawshank
I bought me some penguins.
- Oh?
- Oh my God, you're unreal!
- It's really good!
- [Blake] Yeah!
- Very.
- And then I just followed them
around and I narrated them,
that's what I did.
- That's right, that's right we did.
- [Josh] I know what that's
like, I know what that's like.
- We're not narrated enough.
- Oh my gosh, that's uncanny!
- Not narrated enough.
- Josh, who's next?
- Hey, look guys, y'all
know I'm a rapper man,
I'm a rapper, okay?
That's what I do
and now don't make me bring
back the mullet, okay?
I'm not playing around guys.
- Hey, hey, hey!
- Kelly?
- Oh that's Blake Shelton!
- No, no, no, we did not say that!
- Yes!
- I'll do it man,
I'll do it I'll bring back
the mullet, I'll do it.
- It's Blake!
- [Carson] Gwen, who is it?
- Wait, I thought that
that was, wait, wait,
let's, a team discussion.
- Deliberate, and then I
need your final answer.
- Wait can I, wait,
let's ask one question.
- Okay.
- Billy Ray Cyrus.
- Do you have?
No do you, no that's mine!
You don't!
Do you have a daughter in music?
- Do I?
(laughing)
- Yeah, do you have a daughter
that's really popular in
music named Miley Cyrus?
- No, no I don't, no I don't, no, no.
- Oh you were right, you were right, go.
- Gwen, you wanna answer this?
- Do you have a girlfriend on The Voice?
- That's super hot?
- [Josh] You know I do.
(cheering)
- I won, I won!
- I thought it was Billy Ray!
- Blake Shelton, the correct answer,
as guessed by Gwen Stefani!
- That wasn't enough.
- [Gwen] I got one!
- Dude, I thought it was Billy Ray Cyrus.
(cheering)
- Don't even know your own voice man,
don't even know your own voice.
- That's good!
- Wow, that's pretty good!
- I totally thought it
was Billy Ray Cyrus.
- I can't believe, I'm so excited
for myself that I got one.
- Can you see how competitive I am?
I'm was like,
"That's not our answer!"
- I know!
She goes, "keep, keep meeting!"